hi everybody it's Pete Holmes here in
the uh Pete homm show writers room
trying to answer more of your meat Pete
questions thanks again for submitting
let's take a look at leoe 19 says if I
buy you a fresa can I touch your face
you bring me a cold can of diet
grapefruit soda and you get 15
uninterrupted seconds of touching my
face runner up wins uh touching my
friend's face having my friends touch
your face uh me uh drawing my own face
and then you can touch the drawing of my
face just lots of different things so so
everybody bring a fresa to the show toss
it to me I'll catch it like a fun dad
and then we'll just start touching
things to our
faces Josh wath wraith what's your
middle name and don't make it a funny
haha joke thanks Josh wraith my middle
name is Benedict uh but that sounds way
too scholarly Peter Benedict h Ms sounds
like I should be writing you know
self-help books or pros and uh I'm a
comedian so I just go by old pey pants
it's more fitting for my line of work
Ryan Hood At de
dunan de D dunan how do you tell that to
people uh you said your dad would have
been great with Twitter have you
considered suggesting that your dad join
you know I would like to convince my dad
to join um maybe if there was some way
to tell him that he could awkwardly
flirt with waitresses through Twitter I
think that would be right up his alley
or if there were a way to convey his
Charming Boston accent through the
medium I think that would really take
him over the top just you know Pete's
dad Peta I'm taking your mother to the
carile car show this weekend which is
actually where they are right now if
anyone's at the carile car show they go
every
year at esqualo would like to know will
it really be you Tweeting for from this
account or some assistant I'm glad you
asked Adriana uh it will always be me
and I promise it will never be written
by my favorite comedian Andy Beckerman
who's also a very goodlooking
man that was
perfect I promise all the other ones
will be ritten by
me thanks
[Music]
Andy